[Music]
well just over three weeks ago as
McVeigh quit her job in the cabinet a
Patrice Mays brexit plan in her
resignation letter she said the deal
does not honor the result of the
referendum and fails to secure the right
outcome for the future of our country
and she joins us now for her first TV
interview since do you think government
and welcome morning I'm it feels as if
we've heard everybody else's account of
what happened in that crucial cabinet
meeting where Teresa Mays brexit plan
was signed off apart from yours so what
did happen well obviously I'm not going
to breach confidences of what happens in
cabinet I never have and I won't start
now but I can put some of the record
straight that has already been in the
paper fundamentally at the end after
we'd all been discussing for five hours
about the brexit deal there were voices
of dissent people saying different
things so I asked on the most crucial
issue of a generation could we have a
vote of the cabinet to see exactly where
the various secretaries of state were
where the cabinet ministers were on the
issue it's happened before under
previous administrations so you could
have the vote but obviously it's down to
the Prime Minister it is her cabinet she
can choose to elect what she does but as
I said there were various voices of
dissent and I felt we needed to focus
the mind of people who were taking a
decision that would last longer than us
being in cabinets longer than us being
in Parliament but was about the future
of the United Kingdom so you don't
crimen know why do you think people are
so obsessed with whether female
politicians cried I wonder whether it
was obviously briefed to the papers
afterwards and obviously maybe they
thought that would see me in a negative
light but people who know me know that
I'm forthright I am at fiesty I am a
straight-talking
and quite rightly I'm passionate about
this issue but all we needed to know was
what do people think and in all honesty
I think it says there was a meltdown in
the
the meltdown was from the others not
wanting to put their name next to a vote
it certainly wasn't from me asking for
one
yeah I'm keen to kind of talk about this
because it does further some of the
briefings were pretty unusual shall we
say around new and according to reports
in the press your behavior was described
as hysterical and aggressive as you say
people said you had a meltdown in
October an unnamed Treasury saw said of
you the only thing she knows how to do
well it's a blow dryer is it sexist well
look different people use the media in
different ways to portray a story and to
get an issue out there there was two
things that I wanted to deliver and that
was a brexit that the UK voted for but
unfortunately in the cabinet the
majority of people and those in the key
posts all voted remain from the prime
minister to the Chancellor to the Deputy
Prime Minister to the Home Secretary to
the foreign secretary so obviously
that's obviously an issue there and the
other thing that I wants to do was get
more money for universal credit because
yes it does a heck of a lot of good but
for the most vulnerable it wasn't
supporting so I succeeded in getting in
the budget four and a half billion
pounds extra and again at the time
everybody didn't want that to happen
either so that could be why you've had
briefings because it was on to issues
more money for universal credit and to
to deliver the brexit vote that the
people of the UK put forward okay should
we deal with universal credit because it
feels as if and there's been a lot
written about it people with feelings
from very very strongly about universal
credit and and I know that that's
something that course you were
responsible for up to your resignation
now according to the traceur Trust and
they say on average twelve months after
universal credit is rolled out food
banks see a 52% increase in demand 70%
of recipients find themselves in debt
while waiting for their payments and
only eight percent say that payment
covers their cost of living I mean is
that a record you're proud of
well the Trussell trust there you've got
to look at where the source is coming
from who have been interviewed to give
those comments and notes are from people
coming into the Trostle trust so those
results weren't
authenticated they weren't sort of
verified as such people were in hardship
when they had to wait for those payment
but come through what I will say is and
that's what I spent eight months doing
saying okay how do we sort out one sort
of extreme of people saying it isn't
working at all two other people are
saying it's the best thing that ever
happened
so for 85% of people or more they are
saying it's helping us into work we're
working more than ever before which
we've seen a thousand people every day
each and every day since 2010 are in
work so it's working there but what I
looked at is our but for the people it's
not working for so those are the people
who will find themselves going into the
Trussell trust social people will find
themselves going to our support groups
and budget groups the Christians against
poverty CA the various other
institutions so I met with all them and
said what can we do
hence I thought for the extra four and a
half billion in the budget hence I
fought for one and a half billion pounds
to make sure that the severe disability
premium was there for half a million
extra people so I said how do we make it
work
what money needs to come forward but not
just money it was about how it was
delivered to so people would say how can
we make sure that the payment period and
the assessment period doesn't knock out
our payment how do we make sure that we
get money straight away which you can
get with in advance and going forward
how do we make sure it's not always paid
monthly
it could be paid weekly fortnightly
three weekly for weekly so a lot of that
I've already put in place some of it
will be coming through after the vote in
the house and then further monies are
coming forward next year and that's on
delivery so I said we've got to have
outreach work we've got to have a
flexible fund we've got to look at those
people who you will be hearing for which
it doesn't work for at the moment so a
good government a proper government and
how this system was set up was to be
about it's about being agile it's about
being able to quickly respond to
people's needs and that's what we needed
to do and that's what we are doing and
should continue to do as a compassionate
conservative government and again and I
said how can you give
39 billion to the EU and for what for
and yet I'm fighting desperately for a
few billion for the most vulnerable
people in the UK that cannot be right
now that you're not government anymore
and you don't have to defend Universal
Credit are you sorry for anything
hardships that some people faced what I
will say and I think you've got to look
at it in its entirety the legacy system
it replaced wasn't working so people who
could have got out of poverty and into
work it wasn't working for them they
couldn't work more than 16 hours 24
hours 30 hours so they were trapped in
poverty this for the first time ever
makes work pays it allows people to come
forward and come out of poverty
so again thousands thousands three and a
half million more people we've helped
but those who it wasn't working for we
knew we've got to make it to better and
equally under labour the benefits bill
shot up by 60% they'd made the benefits
system unaffordable and unsustainable
going forward I've always said we took
difficult decisions in 2010 and 2015 to
make it affordable but you know what as
we come out of austerity as we want to
make this work that's what we've got to
do we've now got to look at the freeze
on benefits do we still need that maybe
not remove that and mixed age couples in
the new year how do we support them okay
and let's look forward to next week now
because this vote on Tuesday if it
happens it's going to be absolutely
crucial and a lot of MPs saying that
they can't support the Prime Minister's
deal if it gets voted down as we expect
it will what do you think needs to
happen then the Prime Minister
immediately has to go to the EU and get
a better deal that's what she must do
and there are two key things people talk
about the 585 page document there are
two key things in there one is the
backstop we don't need the backstop we
shouldn't have the backstop the EU says
it doesn't want it we don't want it so
why is it there removed at the same time
I mean you can say that you know no one
wants to be in a traffic jam so why
should there be a traffic jam and the
same you know the reason that there's a
backdrop is to avoid that border I don't
know
I don't think that's the same thing a
traffic jam is there no we are creating
the backstop it isn't there therefore
nobody wants it remove it and the other
bit is the 39 billion pounds why oh why
are we handing over 39 billion pounds
and what for that 39 billion pounds
shouldn't be for the withdrawal
agreement of moving out that 39 billion
pounds has to be used for the future
agreement that has to be for our future
trade agreement with them and if that
isn't happening we cannot agree to this
withdrawal if Terry Mae's cannot get
what you want her to what should she do
should she move to a second referendum
should she call an election or do you
think she should then move to and manage
No Deal well what she said and I've
agreed with her since she started we've
got to come out the customs union we've
got to come out the single market so
it's not an option for you we know we've
got to have control of our laws of our
borders of our money of our sovereignty
of movement of people and therefore she
has got to say as she's always said no
deal is better than a bad deal that's
what we said that's what we agreed in
article 50 is there and we are coming
out of the EU I should apply to me in a
in a Prime Minister's Questions we're
coming out on the 29th of March so
though it's better than the deal on the
table that's what you're saying we've
always said if we cannot come to an
agreement then we will be coming out
without one so we've always said no deal
was better than a bad deal not remain
remain was never there and the people
voted for out so what she's got to say
cuz the EU doesn't want no deal we don't
want no deal so between us of course we
can get a better deal for the UK
backstop goes the 39 billion is for a
future agreement not to talk about an
agreement
who'd paid 39 billions to talk about an
agreement 39 billion is for that
agreement at the same time there's been
some pretty concerning warnings about
the impact of no deal and I know there's
a lot of skepticism about some of the
forecasts but it does feel as if there
is perhaps a you know a unanimous
recognition that there will be an
economic
hit if there is no deal is that a price
worth penny we've heard project fair one
when we heard all of these and coming
back to my department we got told if we
even voted for the referendum half a
million more people would be unemployed
that did not happen we've still got
record rates of employment in fact the
UK has created since 2010 more jobs than
France Spain Ireland Austria Sweden the
Netherlands and Norway put together so
I've heard the project fear stories and
this is yet more of course we can
succeed and of course we want to make
sure that it is a managed a process so
if there is no deal we would have as
we've got now an implementation period
by which we would work together we could
even say he is half the money up front
and then Harvard about there is no
golden period no but why not of course
you could arrange to have one because
you pay for the implementation period
about 10 billion pounds that is not true
you if you've got an implementation for
a deal you would negotiate to have an
implementation for no deal because we
pay for that implementation period and
of course if the EU don't want No Deal
we don't want No Deal what we both want
is to be good neighbors good allies good
friends we are in the same geography so
let's get that free trade agreement is
there to get the other people who don't
want no deal is UK MPs are you not
concerned that because there is such a
majority in the house against a No Deal
scenario that by voting down the Prime
Minister's deal all you're doing is
making a second second referendum more
likely and no breaks is at all look MPs
come to Parliament because the people
elected them now in Parliament by vast
majority we said the people should have
a say we gave the referendum to the
people to have a say they told us it was
either in or out and they said out now
that's what the people said
unfortunately in the house there's too
many MPs
who voted remains so they are going
against the people so when you talk
about trust trust in Parliament trust in
government that's what it's about
they've said you
we've given you our decision now go and
do that don't try and confuse us and in
fact this is something that I heard at
the weekend I was meeting with my
constituents they said you know what
asked when people can't convince people
they try and confuse people and that's
what we feel politicians are doing to us
now we don't want you to confuse us we
know we can get a better deal what are
we paying for nobody wants this back
stop it give us what we asked for which
is brexit which is to come out of the EU
you said to send that to many MPs back
to remain you were talking earlier about
the number of remain supporters in the
cabinet do you think the next leader the
Conservative Party needs to be a brexit
here I think that first of all we've got
to take one step at a time and if and
I'm led to believe today that the Prime
Minister's going to go and have another
go at a negotiation
negotiating with the EU which she wasn't
prepared to do which I asked her to do
in cabinet she wasn't prepared to but if
she goes out and gets this deal that we
want on those two key points well then
she will remain as a la prime minister
because she will have done the deal I
wasn't asked to do and if she doesn't
then it is going to be very difficult
for her but fundamentally what she needs
to resign if she can't get the deal that
you want let's take it's not what I want
it's what the public wants what we voted
for in and out was on that ballot sheet
and the country that always difficult to
know as to exactly what everybody voted
for isn't it no it's rated for different
reasons because we always said we're
coming out of the customs union were
coming out of the single market we will
be in truck control of our borders our
laws our money our sovereignty so people
knew what that was the Prime Minister
has said that for the last two years in
Parliament she said that for two years
so we all knew what it was and obviously
there was a significant debate
beforehand and people knew what it was
for and that's what we've got to do
because it is about how do we get which
john was talking about before the
division in the country people are
saying look I feel not only let down by
our Parliament and our MPs who give us a
referendum and defer
choice to us and what we should be doing
or they defer choice upwards to another
greater authority the EU whatever
elected MPs doing they need to be making
our decisions on with that making
domestic decisions so we want more money
for the police we want more police on
the street 39 billion
wouldn't that be better being spent at
home as well as getting a better deal
and also a trade in deficit of a hundred
billion pounds with the EU that has
grown over the time that we've been in a
you eat the EU no let's strike free
trade deals around the world that now as
the EU admits ninety percent nine zero
percent of future growth is outside the
EU not inside we are a outward-looking
global nation we've been traders with
the globe that's what we need to do and
just find us to end on the leadership
point and if Tories may forget her deal
through if she can't get what you want
her to get from Brussels would you
consider getting an electric no
confidence
well I stood down from the government
because I didn't have confidence in what
it was doing so I've done that because I
didn't have confidence in where it was
going and what it was doing however if
the Prime Minister goes back to the EU
like she's saying now and get a better
deal something she was not preferred to
do when I asked her in cabinet if she is
then I am fully behind it if she can get
a better deal but you know now at the
moment I am looking for a person who can
unite the party behind a brexit deal a
person who believes in brexit who's got
really the full passion to deliver when
you see someone who's doing that well
I've seen the array of people who've
come forward at the moment and I think
if we can all get behind one for me the
most important thing is not the
personalities it is the deal for our
country you're not really making better
well you're not ruling out running for a
leader so if people asked me then of
course you'd say of course you'd give it
serious concern and do it if people ask
me but at the moment I'm looking at
who's in the papers who can we get
behind but it shouldn't be about the
personality it should be
about the country and this deal
[Music]